boa noite a yasmin preparou uma surpresa
para mim é difícil falar depois do bill
gates nã o sã o negócio terrível né
bom é revelando já a umidade além da
barba branca
vocês conhecem um samba do paulinho da
viola que na que diz foi um rio que
passou em minha vida conhecem como é que
o resto é isso aí foi a minha relação
com a educação um rio que passou na
minha vida e meu coração se deixou levar
minha formação inicial não tem nada a
ver com a educação
mas a minha aflição com relação à
educação começa na escola eu sou eu sou
o meu foi o do tipo de aluno que se na
minha época tivesse medo medicalização
eu estaria com a caixa de ritalina no
bolso agora porque me chama de
hiperativo desajustado e outras coisas
enfim fui trabalhar no mundo corporativo
comecei com 20 e poucos anos é como
executivo de uma empresa multinacional
de franquias e franquia você investe
muito em treinamento treinamento
treinamento ouvir essa palavra
treinamento
fui fazer um curso fora do brasil a
respeito disso a respeito de franquia na
universidade americana e dentro do
modelo de negócio de franquia
ouvimos muito falar em treinamento
treinamento treinamento bom já estava
aqui no brasil trabalhando uma outra
empresa
um parceiro nosso investia muito em
treinamento treinamento treinamentos em
toque bacana
vou lá ver como é que é o treinamento e
entrosamento porque ele falava com
empolgação e pessoa tem treinado tem que
ter tratamento igual
que delícia neve ser muito bom aí
cheguei
cheguei um pouco mais cedo e o dia do
treinamento ele fazia treinamento
periódicos na de rh que preparava toda a
estrutura do treinamento bom
ele chegou um pouco antes dele estava
conversando com o pessoal e aí o
cafezinho um lugar fantástico para você
colher informações
meus amigos antropólogos a gente tem que
fazer um estudo sobre a turma que fica
no cafezinho nas empresas né porque você
consegue coletar uma coisa eles viram um
grupo completamente diferente e assim e
hoje é o dia da dor de cabeça dor de
cabeça
ae hoje é o dia o perdoem a expressão da
bunda quadrada
uau mas que história é essa tem uma
economia e na história né ele todo
empipocado falando em treinamento e o
pessoal falando isso e aí eu me lembrei
do meu tempo de escola do meu tempo de
faculdade era a mesma coisa porque
coloquei no título da palestra mas o dia
de hoje foi tão rico que dos sete lotes
que parou de usar só dois ou três porque
eu quero usar os exemplos que eu colhi
com vocês aqui que foi muito legal mas
estudantes do século 21 organizações do
século passado ou do século 19
estudantes do século passado e
organizações do século 21 é a uma
dicotomia tá ea dicotomia que existe
existe também um novo processo
educacional e e tanto dentro da empresa
como nas escolas
bom vamos ver o que é isso
já foi
vou voltar com o velho arizinho né o rua
aristóteles que ele dizia todos os seres
humanos naturalmente desejam
conhecimento todo mundo concorda
naturalmente correto
naturalmente vamos de novo com
repetidores aristóteles que todos os
seres humanos naturalmente desejam
conhecimento cara quem fez o meu
currículo escolar
quem fez os meus programas de
treinamento que eu sofri sofri também
não conhece a palavra naturalmente na me
impuseram isso top-down goela opa goela
abaixo
e isso é um negócio bastante
interessante porque a gente vê é muito
case e na universidade também é case de
sucesso as empresas do vale do silício
que não tem parede
a hierarquia toda horizontal não tem
arquias na quinta negócio bacana e eu
ficar eu tinha uma aflição e do meu deus
a gente tem vamos brincar que vão fazer
uma metáfora zinha isso aqui essa arte a
minha tarefa foi inspirada no site do pr
é aquela cobrinha do que quem leu porque
eu não fiz concurso de misse tá mas eu
li o pequeno príncipe que toda a missa
antigamente dizia é quase um livro de
cabeceira pequeno preto eu não li mas eu
não fiz concurso de miss mas eu li o
pequeno príncipe
vamos imaginar vão fazer junto aqui uma
cobra gigantesca e que ela tivesse sobre
uma timeline que ela estivesse sobre uma
linha do tempo
então até a cauda lá no século 19 tem o
corpanzil no século 20 a cabeça no
século 21
bom a gente tem tanto é
escolas e tantos tantos modelos
educacionais que já estão com a cabeça
no século 21 já existem experiências
bacanas como algumas empresas que estão
no século 21
entretanto a gente também tem modelos
educacionais e tem escolas que estão com
o rabinho lá no século 19
lá no na meiuca do século 20 empresas
também que estão lá no século 19 nos
empresas que estão no século 19 uma
posição a trabalho escravo
olha só a gente achou que em 1888
tivesse acabado com isso né
olha que que loucura
bom eu tinha uma aflição então e foi
quando eu comecei a pensar em modelos
educativos de fato dentro das
corporações
qual era a minha aflição você tinha uma
corporação estava chegando no século 21
entretanto você tinha a cabeça das
pessoas que estavam ingressando nessa
nesta corporação no século 19 ou no
século 20
e isso ia dar algum problema em algum
momento beleza é um problema que a gente
consegue de uma certa forma contornar
você sai de uma coisa um pouco engessada
por uma coisa mais aberta
dói menos vai doer é todo o processo de
um novo aprendizado gera um
desequilíbrio até você se acomodar e se
esse conhecimento
isso não é meu não tá o piaget que falou
dando crédito mas acontece uma coisa e
isso agora me deixa aflita silva que
está aqui me convidou uma vez para uma
roda de experiências de de escolas
criativas de de processo criativo
existem já experiências e vocês vão
ouvir as experiências aqui de escolas
diferentes
e pra aumentar a minha carga eu tive um
encontro com os educadores dossiê aqui
em petrópolis que também estão fazendo o
ano com os meninos do projeto aprendiz
um trabalho diferenciado já preparando
dentro dessa visão vamos falar do do
século 21 é também quebrando a
hierarquia também acabando com classes
está acabando com turmas né
bom aí a minha aflição aumentou só
porque é que a gente também tem muita
empresa ainda no século 20 e no século
e como esses jovens vão chegar nessas
empresas que ainda com hierarquia muito
pesada ainda com paredes fechadas ainda
com o processo muito de cima para baixo
e eu comecei a pesquisar isso daí
qual o caminho que a gente vai vai tomar
onde a gente vai chegar
deixa eu ver se eu vou usar o último
slide a uma outra metáfora também que eu
vou até mudar o o hotel solo francês que
cima é me chama uma tesoura lhe e ele
escreveu um livro chamado apocalipse na
o meu único desejo de viver 150 anos 200
anos era poder enxergar o que diziam
escrever do tempo que a gente está
vivendo agora essas mudanças todas essas
transformações como é que eles vão ver
esse tempo aquela que vão enxergar esse
tempo que nós estamos vivendo de todas
essas mudanças né
de todas essas culturas e do desejo de
não romper também né porque dois mundos
existem você
a gente aprende errado na escola vou
estudar agora antiguidade clássica agora
idade média como se fosse assim
agora a partir de amanhã virou ano você
vir a achar você não está mais na
antiguidade clássica não existem mais os
deuses pagãos
agora você está na idade não é
sim né a idade média ela a a antiguidade
avançou negra na idade média a idade
média avançou na antiguidade recuo na e
isso é bastante interessante
ele usa um termo chamado apocalipse é um
apocalipse bíblico tá então fiquem
tranquilos a gente ainda não o mundo não
vai acabar se a humanidade deixar é mais
o fim de uma era né
uma era que ainda não morreu totalmente
o que a gente vive eo nascimento de uma
outra que ainda não vê totalmente ao
mundo né ea gente está no meio desse
caos
isso é um negócio muito bacana esse é um
negócio muito excitante
apesar de dar um monstrinho na barriga
que vocês vão ver
depois o que é isso bom quando estava
começando a se ver lá fora no coffee
break
veio uma outra metáfora também que eu
acho que é mais bacana ainda imagina o
rio amazonas disse deságuam no mar na
maré baixa é instalar o rio entrando
você vê aquela mancha do rio entrando no
mar mostrando uma aí a maré sobe venha a
pororoca imagino mar entrando
de volta ao rio adentro fazendo aqui e
esse momento que a gente vive essa força
que a gente vive e se muda essa mudança
que a gente vive
bom a gente fala assim educação e
treinamento é qual é a diferença
eu acho que na escola eu recebia
treinamento eu via meu cachorro sendo
treinado e o cara fazia o negócio dá um
biscoitinho pra ele ele obedecia na
escola fazer a mesma coisa não tocava o
sinal do meu disco tinha o intervalo
é aí você tinha pegar geral hd virava hd
opa sair de história estou indo para
geografia e você verá a vaga como se não
é como se a vida não fosse uma coisa só
como se tudo fosse junto e eu sofria com
isso as novas experiências educação que
vocês vão ver aqui na frente
agora a gente precisava levar isso para
a empresa também o treinamento não podia
ser igual a escola não podia ser aquela
coisa
eu vou porque eu vou treinar as pessoas
aí tocava o sininho as pessoas saíam e
um cafezinho reclamava e voltava de lá e
depois o empresário falava assim eu
invisto em treinamento e eles não me
respondem nada porque aí tem os que
deixam de investir na alese eles não
dizem que investe eu gasto em
treinamento e eles não respondem a isso
sabia que aconteceu há uma coisa a gente
começou a anp a empresa é um organismo
vivo vivo é um sistema orgânico feito
por pessoas
o que você acha que está treinando é uma
parte da sua equipe
óbvio que não estou falando de coisas
específicas gente de especificidade de
você ela tem impacto em toda a
organização
então todo o processo educativo ele tem
que envolver ele deve envolver todas as
partes e você trabalha e aí volta nessa
nova nesse novo não nesse modelo de
educação que que tenta emergency uma do
velho onde você trabalha com projetos
onde você trabalha com o seu
autoconhecimento a experiência da favela
olha que barato de de ensinamento de
aprendizagem colaborativa que a gente
tinha na favela
não eu sei fazer isso eu tenho
experiência nisso você aproveitar isso
dentro do ambiente organizacional você
horizontalizar esse fluxo de informação
isso é muito muito gratificante muito
importante a gente cria dentro da
organização
uma coisa chamada inteligência coletiva
a gente consegue criar dentro da
organização
uma coisa chamada é o conhecimento
compartilhado
o conhecimento compartilhado é a gente
consegue criar dentro da empresa núcleos
que se juntam e que depois para
determinados tipos de projetos se
desfazem daqui a pouco estão em outros
esse é um negócio muito bacana e isso é
um processo educativo não é um processo
da escola escola e educação são coisas
completamente diferentes
completamente diferente né isso é
diferente do treinamento que a gente
repetir o modelo de escola quando
indústria na revolução industrial escola
andavam juntos se tocava o sino na
fábrica tocava se na escola de beleza
mas está morrendo isso não está
acontecendo mais e uma coisa que eu vou
revelar pra vocês agora né
as empresas como elas são feitas por
gente
elas têm um ponto g
você sabe o que é o ponto g conhece o
ponto g foi o alemão médico alemão que
descobrir que até um contrassenso
descobriu o ponto do prazer né
e eu vou ensinar a vocês aqui onde é que
a gente descobre o ponto g nas
organizações
tá lá todo mundo levanta a mão direita
ok faz assim com esse dedo aqui não é
aquele dedo com esse dedo aqui tá também
levanta agora o braço esquerdo
vira dá um tremendo beliscão ok
descobrir o ponto g que vibra a
organização é de gente
somos nós né então agora que você já
sabe aonde o ponto g
vamos levar para dentro e não só para
dentro das empresas mas para a vida para
a cidade
o processo de educação é um processo
onde todos colaboram onde todos aprendem
o professor o o o instrutor é apenas o
mediador desse desse conhecimento
tá bom obrigado